I hope you got your [ __ ] in pants on
what you shouldn't man I hope you wear
right now
because you
Armon that [ __ ] your hands
[Music]
when I first met it
jesus said my world was going to get a
whole lot bigger
we found that world we found each other
that bigger world is ours by right those
who use and take and kill we end up
thank you your majesty what for being
such a cool dish with everything we've
beaten everything we've endured
everything we've risen above everything
we've become no matter what comes next
we've won we've already won
[Applause]
[Music]
other fighting sister farm kept up now
we need to win let me come with you
[Music]
you need to correct you on that point we
need to keep our faith in each other if
we can hold on to that with everything
we have the future is ours the world is
ours over your ears
trust the kid yourself that's the plan
and on this day we begin to reshape this
world and oh ha ha I don't die
[Music]
Oh
whatever comes next whatever happens
we've already won so let's break this
down everybody I'm still doing Walking
Dead videos people have been asking just
because it took me a while to get to
this video there was a lot of comic-con
stuff so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'll be doing episodes when
it premieres in October - it seems like
they're going to do part 1 of all-out
war during the first half of the season
part 2 the second half and slowly slide
into whispers territory with the volume
22 from the comics which is a new
beginning so I'll mention a little bit
about whispers at the end of this but
there was so much footage I don't want
to turn this into a 15 minute video so
I'll try to keep it as concise as
possible but the pitch is pretty simple
you have Dwight betraying negan so they
have a mole on the inside now Maggie has
stepped up in his leading hilltops so
you have her Jesus Rick's group at
Alexandria Ezekiel the kingdom and of
course the tiger not going to make the
tiger ride the bench for the first
episode Walking Dead Season 8 now with
100 percent more tiger and then you have
all the Oceanside people who donated all
their guns they'll probably rope in a
couple more groups from the comics Magna
is the character they haven't introduced
yet but she figures in during all-out
war she has a small group that's kind of
like the scavengers at least inside when
they brought the scavengers on the TV
show they were meant to be an original
thing they're not based on anybody in
the comics so Jadis is completely new
but I think she just meant to be an
agent of chaos like you don't know which
way she's going to go she betrayed the
survivors in favor of negan who gave her
a better deal but what's to say that she
won't just turn around and betray him
so if Rick can do them one better then
it'll come right back as much as they
suck but I love the way they opened this
trailer with Megan and father Gabriel so
even though the survivors are all about
taking it to negan and they do have the
benefit of all these other people
they're trying to rally behind them you
kind of know which direction it's headed
it's the slow down fall of negan but
he's not going to go quietly like you
see him banging Lucille on the table
he'll be as terrible as ever if you've
read the comics please don't post
spoilers about what happens to him
but if you want to you can read the
comics they will be relatively true to
his storyline there's also Eugene who
doesn't feature too prominently in the
trailer and now everybody's wondering
about
old man Rick what is the deal so they
explained that we'll learn an episode
one what that's all about
they didn't confirm that it was a time
job like it might not be actual Rick in
the future it might be their spin on
It's a Wonderful Life because the scene
looks so similar to when he woke up from
his coma in the bed you just saw his
face there so that's what it's meant to
be a mirror so odds are this is a dream
sequence and it's just going to show us
what his life might have been like had
things gone down very differently but
it's not going to be the entire season a
lot of people heard that there was going
to be a time jump at the beginning of
season seven and they thought that that
meant the entire season was going to
jump forward years into the future and
it was going to be some Karl twist where
it would explain why he looks so much
older because he's aging way faster than
Karl in the comic books did but it seems
like Karl's going to be around for at
least the first couple of episodes they
haven't said officially whether or not
he's resigned his contract so I don't
know what the status is on that you can
tell how they're trying to make this
seem a little bit more fun so I think in
response to the drag that season seven
turned into they're trying to make this
a little less of a bummer so you'll
still see big WTF moments but they won't
be quite as depressing as they were
during season seven so just let me know
what you guys think about all this
viewership really did lag a little bit
during season seven I was even wondering
if people wanted me to keep making
videos for it but as long as people are
keep watching and as long as you really
enjoy the show I'll keep doing it so
they'll be premiering in October just
like they normally do I'll do more
videos as they release more trailers but
just let me know what you guys feel
about Season eight so far if you have
read the comics just be careful if
you're talking about really specific
stuff from the all-out war arc
especially with negan and Rick Grimes
and the bigger characters but while you
wait for everything you can click here
for a brand new defenders trailer that's
dropping in a couple weeks and you can
click here for my new Game of Thrones
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you